Kia Scott frost how are you coach Frost
I'm doing well man how you been how have
you been I've been great it's been a
crazy year or so but excited to be back
home and love being here and working
with my alma mater what is that like I
mean for somebody who's been there and
done that as a player at that
institution of higher learning for Tom
Osborne and now are you in his office I
don't know what even the what what even
the the the situation is there in
Nebraska I'm sure everything's been
upgraded since then but are you even or
are you in a Tom Osborne office at all
I'm not the coach's office is long gone
I was in the South Stadium here in
Memorial Stadium they built a new
facility about ten years ago and I'm up
here North but I do have coach Osborne
in my office quite a bit I think he's
glad to have some Nebraska folks back in
here and he's come up and see us
probably about once a week at least then
what do you talk about if you don't mind
me being prying on that what do you talk
about with Tom Osborne you know we just
kind of talked about life in fact I had
a really good couple mornings in May he
and I he took me turkey hunting out just
northwest of Lincoln here and we sat in
a little six foot by six foot tent for a
few hours a couple mornings and man he's
the type of guy that anytime you're
around him he there's so much wisdom
that comes out of what he says that it's
just fun to listen to him no it's
interesting because again as you heard
in my intro and I'm sure you know where
my alma mater is right there in the Big
Ten I mean we as Wolverines viewing Jim
Harbaugh coming back and taking the
reins that is a savior coming back and
reading so much into what he means and
does I believe there's a situation
similar to what's going on there in
Nebraska what do you say to all the corn
Husker fans that are reading a lot into
you and what you can do quickly there
well I firmly believe we can get it done
here it's gonna take a lot of hard work
and and we have a lot of steps to take
that are right in front of us but you
know I'm a fan of college football and
have been my whole life and I've said
this before I think it's interesting how
some of the blueblood programs around
the country Michigan and Nebraska and a
bunch of others
have had their glory years and then
inevitably with every one of them
there's a period of time where maybe
they got away from what worked or they
had the wrong leadership or whatever it
was and went through a period of years
where they they struggled and didn't
accomplish the same things that they
accomplished when they at their height
and Nebraska has definitely gone through
a little bit of that after coach solet's
and coach Osborne left here and think
that times finally right and
everything's lined up the right people
are on campus and and we're excited
about the team we have to get to work to
get Nebraska back up to where it should
be in in the status of college football
well you were in the big house late in
September and the reason why I bring
that up again is it's not gonna be your
first game coaching in the big house you
were there were youth CF a couple of
years ago and we all understand what you
were able to do there go from winless to
undefeated how did you do that
Scott frost it was tough we had a lot of
great coaches there we had a lot of
great kids there and the best thing that
happened is everybody came together and
and worked for each other and we were
all part of something that was bigger
than ourselves and it was it was tough
you know first year we got better and
went six and six including a drubbing up
in the big house and our kids played
really hard in that game but we were
probably outmatched quite a bit in that
one and that was just one of the steps
along the way I tell you everything
really came together this past season
and there was so much love in the
building and everybody working hard for
each other that I think that was a group
that was able to accomplish a lot of
special things well I got to meet you
Keane Griffin up close and personal at
the combine he became internationally
famous after his performance there what
what did you see in Shakima when you
first met him that that you knew that
the rest of the world has found out the
first three things you notice about [ __ ]
came right away spending time with him
is first his personality he's just got
the kind of gregarious personality that
you always want to be around he's fun
he's he works hard he's funny he's just
the type of guy that when you walk into
the building you're glad to see every
day
and the second obvious thing about him
was he is just a freak athlete he long
jumped over 24 feet in high school you
never saw what he ran is 40 in which is
a lot of faster than what I've seen you
run by the way there's a lot of people
who could stake that claim Scotto beyond
fosters he says we'll find out in the
third hour of this show we'll definitely
find that one out I was kind of mad I
feel like I'm a time pillar until you
get Cleary darling well you know what
Scott were you're right we're just
putting the lotion in the basket for the
first couple hours essentially what
we're doing but he did run it fast 40
and I did love meeting him and I love
meeting his family and obviously his
brother and and what he can do at the
next level and what he was able to do
with your program was really I mean it
was really something to behold and and I
just loved the way that everybody just
latched onto it it's international Scott
I know if you're aware of that it is I
then I think it's great for him it's a
great story and I think he's benefited
from that but I you know I selfishly I
don't want it to get lost within that
story that he's a great football player
and I think he's going to prove that I
think there was a lot of NFL teams that
probably took him off their board
because of the fact that he had one hand
but there just weren't very many college
football players in the country last
year that were as talented and as
productive as him and I think a lot of
people were gonna be really surprised at
how well he does and NFL football all
right couple more minutes left with
Scott frost of Nebraska formerly of UCF
before we turn the page on UCF do you
feel even now still months later that it
is right for UCF to raise a banner talk
about half a championship if not being a
national champion last year you know
every time I make one comment about that
it gets blown up so I've kind of moved
on and UCS moved on and it's time for us
to all move on I will say that any any
kind of accolades that that team gets
they deserve that was a special group of
guys that accomplished something in a
two-year stretch that I don't know if
ever
Dunnigan in college football and I'm
proud of that team and I'm proud of
those guys you know historically you
mentioned earlier in the in the
broadcast there's been a lot of split
championships and you know going back
when there wasn't a definite national
championship game with a BCS or and
people were just playing in bowl games
there's a lot of situations where two
undefeated are great teams they didn't
get an opportunity to play each other
and you know I believe in 97 it probably
deserved to be split and I've kind of
said publicly even in 94 when Nebraska
it was crowned champions champion Penn
State had a great team was undefeated
and probably deserved a share of it too
and you know until we get to a playoff
and I'd love to see it being a team
playoff there's always been always going
to be situations that arise where where
somebody gets shut out of the thing and
it's the same that happened to had to
happen to our team but that doesn't take
away from anything that that group
accomplished so let me get in a little
deeper into that eight teams I am with
you I am with you I would have loved to
have seen UCF take on Alabama as maybe
there's even just a one versus eight
seed just throwing that out there I'm
not I'm not pegging anybody for I would
have loved to have seen that how can
that be squared though I mean as a coach
as you know how long of a season it
already is do you have any concerns
about that because that's always going
to be coming right back at and you
talked about 97 if there are more
playoff games people say that it would
it would defray the regular season but I
am with you how do you respond to that
well first of all I don't think it takes
away from the regular season because if
you're not you know at least a one maybe
two loss team you're not even in the
conversation and the teams that aren't
don't have those type of records won't
be in the top eight anyway and I think
every game is still going to matter I
don't think it makes the season long if
you I think you can address that problem
and you know right now because we're
coming out of a bull system you still
the the way it works right now you still
make the semifinals like a bull
experience and I knew that from the
first
play off when I was at Oregon and we
played Florida State in the Rose Bowl in
one and the whole week was like we were
at the Rose Bowl and then we had to turn
around and go try to play a great Ohio
State team the next week and I think if
you're going to go to eight you start
the playoffs earlier and in I you know
the speaker for myself if I knew I was
in the playoffs I would gladly sacrifice
quote unquote Bowl experience in order
to to get the playoff started and maybe
the semifinals can be on New Year's Day
and then there's one week left that only
two teams have to play in after the bowl
season is over so I think you can
address those things that I think it
would also address the the problem you
know if you have an undefeated team
going into a conference championship and
somebody else beats them you're not
going to take a conference champion
you're going to take the team that maybe
has one loss and I think an eighteen
playoff would allow you to have five
conference champions and three at-large
teams that would include a team like
that that was undefeated and lost late
or potentially a team like UCF last year
that probably deserved to be in the mix
or something like that
I'm huzzah Scott frost I want to end
this conversation by going full circle
we mentioned Tom Osborne being in your
office obviously a major influence for
you being your college head coach your
first head coach in the pros was Bill
Parcells
being drafted by Parcells as a rookie
quarterback any of those experiences
somehow creep into your coaching style
anything of that sort Scott I tell you I
had a very average to below average NFL
career rich but it couldn't have been
any better for a future coaching career
you know I got to spend time around Bill
Parcells and Bill Belichick and Jon
Gruden and Mike Tomlin and Rod Marinelli
and Todd Bowles and Raheem Morris and a
bunch of guys that have accomplished a
lot in this game and I'd have been a
fool not to have my ears open and listen
to a lot of things that made those guys
great coaches and and definitely was
able to learn a lot from all of them
okay and then I guess I'm mandated to
ask you this question last one if there
was a national championship game in 1997
you versus Michigan what happened Scott
Frost what happened I don't think I
don't think you and I would have the
same opinion that
you know anybody that plays on a great
team has a lot of confidence in their
team and you won't find a Nebraska on
that team that doesn't think we're to
want and I've come across a lot of
Michigan people that feel the same way
so that's it but it's great that both
teams can put 19 in 1997 on their
Stadium and say they were champions
coach look I'm very happy for you and I
look forward to seeing what you do in
the big ten and I know I'm my crew that
on certain fall days but please come
back anytime I really am pleased for you
and congratulations on your your new gig
and best of luck hey great to be on
thanks for it's appreciate it you got it
at coach underscore frost the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience